hey have you heard about Twitter's data
breach employees that are getting leaked
have you heard about LastPass data
getting breached have you heard about
Facebook getting hacked there are so
many news that we hear day in and day
out in this world and they are so common
in recent times we all know how big is
the scope of cyber security and it's
increasing day by day statistics show
that over 1 million job openings will be
there by the end of 2023 and the fact is
less than 50 percent of individuals are
actually skilled to do the job less than
50 percent and even after the Advent of
AI it's the same as digitization
increases more and more people are
coming online more and more businesses
are doing their business online coming
up with their assets online after covet
there is 600 percent increase in cyber
attacks and I'm not kidding and there is
a big fact check that every 38 seconds
there is a targeted Cyber attack
happening somewhere in the world so what
is cyber security cyber security is an
industry where we apply techniques and
tools used to protect a computer related
system namely software Hardware or a
network from cyber criminals or hackers
and honestly cyber security as a whole
is a very huge field when people say
about I am getting a job in cyber
security how to get a job in cyber
security there is no job in cyber
security as such you won't get it there
are many Fades there are many
disciplines many domains inside that so
you need to get a job inside that
because there are so many systems
diverse systems that have their own life
cycle to secure for example you might
have heard about different types of
softwares namely web applications mobile
applications maybe Android or iOS
desktop applications iot applications
and many more for a job in cyber
security you can be a destroyer or a
protector you can join both the sides of
the coin for an offensive job you hack
and find bucks for a defensive job you
identify attacks and stop them and this
is a very high level simplification of a
cyber security job even if you go inside
red team and blue team there are so many
many different domains like namely
appsec Cloud SEC forensic investigator
SOC iot malware analyst incident
responder and so on and the most common
jobs you might have heard about in cyber
security are pen tester for offensive
jobs vapt or red team and for defensive
job it's SOC SOC analyst or a dfr
analyst or a blue teamer and if I go in
deep on all the domains will be out of
scope for this video I'm here to give
you a general overview of every domain
and how to create a career potentially
out of that and I'll give you a roadmap
for the exact things that you will do
and you should do I cannot tell you
exactly what to do because there is no
perfect roadmap for anything but I'll
just give you the bare minimums and my
recommendations what I would suggest you
to do so let's get started but one
problem I wanna tell you that I can tell
you what to learn and how to learn it
but you'll need to find the resources to
learn because there are very scattered
there is no single course that can teach
you everything so the problem with
people is that they'll go there they'll
find resources on Google they'll learn
from scattered resources and the problem
will be that they will not have complete
knowledge of the same domain in deep
they'll pick up voids between their
knowledge so it will affect their career
but what if someone shows you the exact
things to learn and make your industry
ready for a domain I'm gonna talk about
simply learns industry ready cyber
security program that will teach you
in-demand skills in just six months and
your career can be started right away
this program is Advanced executive
program in cyber security by simply
learn in collaboration with triple RT
Bangalore where you will learn this in
demand skills from their top faculty
with real world scenarios and here you
will learn practical knowledge by
solving practical Labs with popular
tools including necess and verb Suite
after the completion of your course you
will get a completion certificate from
triple it Bangalore in a transcript to
validate your learning apart from that
you will get a virtual internship from
npci National payment operation of India
in which you will get four projects
where you will have to solve cyber
security problems by identifying issues
or vulnerabilities in a system and tell
how to secure them sounds exciting right
so if you want to be eligible for this
program you need to have a bachelor's
degree at least and one year work
experience in any relevant security
field and some basic knowledge of
programming so if you are interested
then link is in the description go to
the link read all the description and
all the details click on apply now fill
all your details and just enroll right
away in order to learn cyber security
you need to First learn some
prerequisites it's not that easy to jump
directly into that so first of all you
need to love computers you need to fall
in love with them I am serious so first
of all the very basic skill you need to
learn is computer fundamentals so IO
input output software Hardware how
memory management is done Disk
Management memory Process Management
Windows and Linux in both the OS and I'm
not kidding you need to learn system
administration level of courses you can
do a plus and then you need to learn
virtualization too how to run an OS over
OS and multiple OS and you can find all
those courses on YouTube you don't have
to wander around anywhere and waste your
time everything you can get free so the
next thing that you need to learn is the
most important thing they want to talk
about is computer networking so that's
the most important thing no single
computer can be hacked if it's not
connected to anything else so there is
no isolated system in cyber security so
you need to learn how computers are
connected the basic TCP IP and OSI
models and all the layers inside that
the most important layers are data link
layer till the application layer so the
application layer is most important here
all the protocols that you will learn
HTTP SMTP FTP SSH and everything the
most common in web is HTTP so you need
to be thorough inside that that is
indirectly related to internet internet
runs on IP addresses and port numbers so
the third and fourth layer are very
important for you to understand how
network works if you want to be a
network pen tester then IP IP layers and
IP protocols and IP types I had a
formats TCP UDP port numbers and all the
details inside that and I'll repeat
again 90 of hacking is based on network
so you need to learn them you can learn
from books there is some good book I can
recommend data communication and
networking from Frozen that I personally
used but you can watch YouTube videos
you can watch courses and I'll repeat
again 90 of hacking is based on network
so internet is networking the third
thing is Linux and shell programming if
you don't know majority of world's
servers are based out of Linux because
it's robust some examples for robust
Linux servers are rhel and send OS and
even after that the attacking machine
that most of the hackers use in the
world is based out of Linux because
Linux is open source Linux is robust
it's customizable so you know everything
about it and you need to be learning
shell programming because even if you
don't have any tools with guis you'll
need to learn how to use them on command
line it's very important because as a
hacker you might have seen that command
line window a black screen or a green
text so that's very fancy right that is
what is terminal or a shell you need to
learn that to be cool just kidding
learning Linux is very easy you can
start from a beginner friendly OS like
Ubuntu it's very easy to learn you can
just explore and try things there learn
tools and then you can switch to a
hacker OS called Kali you might have
heard about it right many things so then
you can learn how to use tools because
it's made for penetration testers buy
pen testers and there are many tools you
can you can Master you can learn the
techniques of hacking and it will be
very cool but first you need to make
sure that you're doing things right and
ethically and by shell programming in
Linux I mean Bash that's the current
standard of shell being used so there
are a lot of commands very simple
commands once you keep typing you will
remember in your subconscious mind lscd
PWD CP all of these commands will be
used in your daily basis and the next
thing is programming do we need to learn
programming many people ask me this
question is there a need I don't know
how to code I'm very weak in that but
I'll tell you if you opt for a offensive
job in a pen testing world you need to
learn how to program and how code is
written because in a corporate world
there is white box pen testing you get
access to the source code so you have to
extensively review the source code and
then find issues in that so there is no
way out eventually you'll need to learn
it but at the starting for a beginner I
won't say it's a big deal or a big
headache to conquer but you can keep it
on hold for some time just familiarize
yourself with cyber security concept and
once you feel you are ready to learn
programming on the site along the way
then you can just start it because
eventually you'll need to learn it at
the end so why not start early so it's a
very simple concept right how a software
is made what is it made of code right so
if you need to hack a software you need
to learn how it is coded how it is
written so you need to learn to read
code so you need to learn many basic
concepts of programming like data types
variables uh conditionals Loops classes
and objects and these are enough so
these are the major Concepts that you
need to learn in basic programming and
you can pick up any programming language
that you can Master but you don't know
which programming language will come
before you to hack or test it can be
anything so you have to learn the basic
concept the syntax are different in all
the languages but the basic concept is
same so these are the prerequisites that
I will recommend you to learn at the
bare minimum and these are very crucial
so once you get through all of them and
do brainstorming and keep everything in
mind and you've learned everything then
you can start go learn cyber security
from various sources because they are
very scattered and even then there is no
single course of cyber security there
are many domains many disciplines and
each of them have different things to
learn and topics and even here I have a
bare minimum concept to learn for you
all is the Avast top 10 so what is wasp
or was a foundation of web security that
is developed and designed for web
developers and security researchers to
make them aware about cyber attacks and
how they can secure themselves and every
three or four years they will release an
extensive list of top 10 vulnerabilities
or attacks that is the result of
consensus of all the issues and attacks
reported recently through statistics and
they have extensive resource Factory for
all of them including labs and tools and
they are all free so if you see the list
you will see some examples like Access
Control security misconfiguration secure
design ssrf I'm not going to take all
the names but for each attack type they
have their own descriptive documentation
they'll make you understand as a hacker
and also as a developer how you can see
how we can identify the issue in your
code and how you can fix them optimally
and even for all the issues there are
Labs that you can solve to practice them
and realize them in real world they have
many Labs including or wasp Juice Shop
believe up you can just set up them on
your local machine or just run a cloud
instance and then just practice them and
even they conduct conferences by the
name of cost they also have their
YouTube Pages you can learn from them
and they have a lot of documentation
they have a two low ASP Zap for pen
testing just like burp Suite so they
have very good resources and I'll tell
you one thing that practice is the key
if you learn a concept today don't just
leave it like that the theory won't help
you in getting a job you need to
practice the concept each and every
attack issue framework vulnerability you
need to practice them on your own
Hands-On with your own Labs so I'll tell
you that you know already that how
technology changes drastically every day
so you need to get updated and be
proactive in learning new things this is
a complete practical field okay and then
there is another resource just like
wasps there is another resource called
ports rigger they have their own Labs
called Web Security Academy where you
can learn all the concepts of web
security and solve the labs online which
are free and also they have a tool
called burp Suite that's the most
popular tool that every hacker uses when
they want to pen test something so even
I use that even you will use that
everyone uses that and every Cyber
attack has an impact and a risk involved
in that and there is a huge difference
between risk and impact that's where our
risk and compliance teams come into
place the risk management there is a
different job profile called GRC or
governance risk and compliance with many
other names but the concept is the same
that you find an issue but how to fix
that and how to fix the risk the risk is
associated to the business the risk and
compliance team will relate every risk
to the business impact or objective so
the basic goal of cyber security is to
identify and realize your risk and then
to contain it and reduces as much as
possible that's where hacker come in to
realize those risks and if I talk about
defensive jobs their job is to learn
digital forensics and incidents so they
need to learn how to do Incident
Management how to review the locks how
to use Siem tools and how to correlate
data so they'll have to find evidences
of all the attacks that recently
happened and continuously monitor the
network events and create alerts so that
they can respond to them so they have to
do a lot of Investigation correlation
and Road cost analysis of the issue once
they find the root or the culprit
they'll try to reduce the risk and
prevent that from happening in the
future so likewise we have many domains
and each domain has its own deep
knowledge that you cannot gain that's
not possible you need to select a domain
of your choice that you can only get by
research by yourself study no College
can teach you that but I'll tell you one
more problem I told you everything that
you need to learn you learn everything
you gain all the skills you do a lot of
practice that you know that you know
everything that you can do and perform
those attacks but how will you tell the
HR how will the HR know so it's not just
about acquiring skills it's also about
proving in your skills that's what
happens when you look for a job when you
hunt a job and look for a good career
the first thing is to build your resume
professionally that's the short listing
criteria you won't even get to the
interviews if you don't take this
seriously so I'll tell you what all
things you'll need to add in your resume
so the first thing is degree
unfortunately you need to do a degree in
CS or it Branch because most companies
want that and my preference for a degree
is B Tech then BCA and then BSC but if
you are a math student the b-tech is the
best option if you are an art student
then you don't have any choice you can
do BC or BSC if you are from any other
Branch like electrical mechanical civil
you haven't done bachelors in CS or it
then you can go for Masters you should
go for Masters but I won't say it's very
hard requirement or a very necessary
thing to do I didn't do Masters myself
but if you want you can do that it will
be a good option for a job if you're
getting good placements in that college
but I'll tell you that the degree is the
only thing that we require we don't care
about anything else and how you do it
you just need that certificate so you
can do private programs distinct
learning anything doesn't matter the
second thing is projects they are very
important as a fresher especially
because you don't have any work
experience so you need to do something
apart from your learning so whatever you
learned whatever skills you gained you
should apply them somewhere to prove it
like that's the point so you can apply
our cyber security skills with any other
domain like AI Cloud security blockchain
web3 include anything combine them and
create a good project with many project
ideas that I can give you and then you
need to open source that because you
need to show the employer because they
will demand and require your link that
they can verify themselves because there
are many false alarms out there and I've
already told you how you can do projects
in cyber security the simply learn
internship from mpci from that advanced
executive program will give you four
projects that's all you need that's all
you need to code so you can put that
link in your resume along with your
LinkedIn that's equally important and
the next thing is certifications and
I'll tell you that if you do a
certification and you don't need to do a
master's degree at all it's not required
do some good certifications because they
teach you a skill in a particular niche
in deep in a shorter time so it won't
take you two years it will just take you
one month two months three months or
maximum six months if you are good
enough and there are many certifications
right now in the market that you can
choose but for India for an HR I think
ceh is the most basic certification that
the look because they all know that but
skill wise eh is not good it's just a
theory Examination for practical skills
for actual skill development you should
give oscp because HR loves it and also
you'll get a better job with a better
salary and a better company with oscp
because it's more skillful and more
better than ceh holder and also the
problem is with oscp is the price that's
why not many people take it it's more
costly but if you want to be cheaper and
gain some practical skills too you can
do e-learn certifications like ejpt
ecppt or eccpt you can correct me ewaptx
those are very practical and very good
certifications not on the level of oscp
very close to them but still they are
cheaper so it's a good deal there are
about certifications that are more
relevant in outside countries like
Security Plus pen Test Plus crtp so that
you can do that if you want to plan for
some foreign countries or foreign jobs
so likewise two three certifications are
more than enough and now comes work
experience the internship I've already
told you how to get an internship just
go to the simply lens program and you'll
get it just enroll there so that's not a
problem for you but if you want extra
internships you'll go to the LinkedIn
create an account today you'll need to
be actively involved in LinkedIn and
don't use any other social media more
than LinkedIn because it's going to help
you in your job search the most so
connect with people do an internship at
least three months or maybe maybe six
months that will gain you a good
experience on how work is done in an
industry and then even that company
itself can give you a job offer called
PPO and you can join with a good package
or a salary so now your resume is strong
enough you can actively look for jobs
and that too it will be the same in
LinkedIn so you need to build as much
connections as possible with good people
working in a good company in your
desired cyber security domain connect
with HRS and approach them talk to them
personally share your resume be
professional be polite be kind and make
sure that you reveal a sense of passion
inside you and building a good Network
in LinkedIn helps a lot you will get a
lot of referrals if possible if you
don't know what referral is is you can
just get into a company with a trust of
another person that's already working in
that company and getting a referral
makes your job hunt much easier you land
a job much easier because you'll get
interviews and even if you make some
mistakes in your interviews it will be a
trust fact matter they will be tolerable
and they'll select you and for a job
hunt I have seen people talking to me
coming back saying that they are not
getting a job they have tried hard
enough but when I ask them how many
companies you have applied on they say
only five or ten that doesn't make sense
you need to apply at least 50 to 100
companies because the average reward
rate is 10 so if you apply in 50
companies you will get reply from five
of them so that's the rate and keep that
in mind try hard as you can so when your
resume is shortlisted you'll have three
to four technical rounds with a
managerial round these are the average
figures and if you are applying for an
offensive job like a pen tester you'll
get you'll expect OS top 10 and code
review questions definitely and scenario
based questions are a very common and
good companies today because they'll
have to test you on a hypothetical
situation how you handle the situation
what is a decision-making approach and
how you solve the problems in very
stressful environment how you can work
under stress and don't even lose your
compose and calm in those situations so
the technical skills are not enough you
need to have some soft skills like
communication skills listening skills
decision making skills and always have a
growth mindset I'll tell you one simple
key to getting a job in cyber security
is to understand the risk of your assets
and learn how to contain them and adapt
to the ever evolving and changing threat
landscape cyber security is an
ever-evolving field its scope is not
going to get declined anytime soon it
will just keep improving so the only
problem with people is that they don't
learn consistently so you need to learn
consistently and be aware of all the
technological updates around you and you
should be good so all the best for your
next cyber security job that's all I got
for today and don't forget to enroll
into advanced executive program that's
the flagship course that will make you
industry ready in cyber security along
with an internship so that's all for
today thank you for watching